all right so let's start with this yeah
let him know man before this happened
when michael with mj came
to the arena he came uh he came late
because he was at that nascar thing
right people didn't think he was gonna
come i think no they think he was coming
so he walked in he was trying to tell me
something he knew what he wanted to say
and he was trying to talk to me about
the charlotte game
about the hornets game when i had 39 and
i came through i came through with the
clutch shots
he was trying to tell me that and then
something they were like trying to rush
him because i think they were trying to
rush him because the 75 they were trying
to get everyone organized to get the
photos done and everything and get
everything right
it was something that he i know he
wanted to say and he was from the videos
i've seen of mj already before this
happened
everything was super competitive with
him magic johnson telling me about monte
carlo he's like 101 right now
i was like okay fj came in on violence
mj mj looks at me and he goes um
i remember what you did to my team i
i seen i seen what you did to my team
[ __ ] you yeah i said yeah
i like this energy
yeah i like this energy
that's why you see me writing the video
go yeah
and the funniest part
mj's so iconic is so and so competitive
he looks back at me and goes yeah
yo i was crying
[Music]
look at this
yeah i was so with the energy y'all
sadder they haven't continued
i love it